GOOD MORNING.
THIS RULES CAN WAIT FOR THURSDAY
FOR PHONE SEX IS HEREBY CALLED
ORDER. OF PEACE VIA ADVISER
AUDIO VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BEING MADE IN A
SAUCEPAN TELEVISED. AMENDED
SECTOR PIECE CALDERON COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM HERE CARILLO.
CERVANTES HERE FRIEDMAN
GALLAGHER.
GRACIA. MANAGED CARE PLANS AREA
SOLACE
WALDRON.
WE HAVE A QUORUM OF. AND WE HAVE
A CONSERVATIVE THE SPORTING HIS
OUR MOTION ON THE CONSENT
AGENDA.
MOVE ON THIS GROUP SECOND BY
MISTER CUNNINGHAM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY.
I COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CARILLO. CARILLO
AYE CERVANTES AYE CERVANTES AYE
FRIEDMAN GALLAGHER GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE MAYES AYE MAYES AYE
IN THIS AREA SOLID SIDE SOLIS
AYE WALDRON FEATHER.
BUT MOST OF PASS AT THIS BILL
SCREWS JORDAN TAKE YOU VERY MUCH